The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
All right.
What we are working on today is
we are still talking about
buffers.
This is from the handout from
Friday.
And we will be continuing
throughout today and probably a
little bit on Wednesday on
acid-base titrations.
This is all in the acid-base
equilibrium unit.
We were talking about buffers.
And so a buffering agent is
something where you can add acid
or base and the pH stays pretty
much neutral.
You usually add an acid and its
conjugate base in the form of a
salt, or you add a base and its
conjugate acid in the form of a
salt.
You have a dynamic equilibrium
going.
And when you add acid or base,
the buffering system acts as a
source of protons or a sink of
protons to keep the pH pretty
much constant.
Let's work through a buffering
problem and consider first the
initial buffering material.
And then what happens if you
add something to it,
you stress the system,
add an acid or a base,
how the pH is affected by that.
In this case,
we are adding one mole of an
acid and 0.5 moles of its
conjugate base in the form of a
salt, the form of a sodium salt
in this case.
And they are added together,
and you add water and bring the
total volume up to one liter.
And you are given information
about the Ka of this particular
acid and asked to calculate the
pH under these conditions.
You can write this out,
as we've seen before,
as an acid in water leading to
hydronium ions and the conjugate
base.
And you can set up a table to
see how much you have in the
beginning and what you will have
at equilibrium.
We can set up this initial
molarity, change in molarity and
equilibrium molarity.
But this time we have something
different.
Now we have acid and the
conjugate base when we start.
In the problems we have looked
at, up until this point,
these guys were both zero when
we started, but in a buffer
problem it is not zero.
You have some amount in there.
And so we had one mole in one
liter, or molarity of 1.5 moles
in one liter or 0.5 molar.
Now, as it comes to
equilibrium, we have the same
kind of change.
We have minus x over here,
plus x here,
and plus x here.
And then, at equilibrium,
we would have 1 minus x,
x, and 0.5 plus x on the other
side.
And, really,
a lot of the trick to doing
these buffer problems is
remembering that you are
starting with something here and
here.
It really is not much more
complicated than that
recognition.
And you would need to have
both.
Otherwise, it is not going to
be a good buffer.
Now, if you have this
information set up,
you know the Ka,
we can solve for x.
And x is what we want,
because we want pH.
And pH is minus log of the
hydronium ion concentration.
We can set this up.
We are given the Ka.
And this is going to be equal
to products over reactants,
the concentrations at
equilibrium.
We have hydronium ion,
the conjugate base over the
conjugate acid.
And so we can fill this in,
0.500 plus x times x over 1
minus x.
Now, here you can do what
we talked about last time.
And that is to first simplify
and see if we can get rid of
these x's here to make it easier
to solve, or you can use the
quadratic equation.
But on the exam,
with the calculators you have,
that is a little more
time-consuming,
so it is nice to see if you can
simplify.
Basically we are saying,
how big is x if x is a small
enough number that it doesn't
really change this 1 or this
0.5.
Then you can sort of ignore it
and solve for x that way.
This is just written up again
that we had on the last side.
We are going to first try the
approximation that x is small
compared to 1 and compared to
0.5 and solve that way,
and then go back and check and
see whether that was valid or
not.
If we assume it is small,
we can rewrite that equation as
0.5 times x over 1.0,
which makes it easier to solve
and get an answer for x.
Which in this case is
3.54x10^-4 molar.
And now we can go back and take
this number, divide it by 0.5,
and see whether it is less than
5% of 0.5.
We are going to check the
assumption and say is this
small?
And you don't need to do both.
If it is small compared to 0.5,
it will also be small compared
to 1.0, so you can just look at
the smaller number of the two.
Here it is less than 0.1%.
That is less than 5%,
so that assumption was okay.
You can just go ahead with this
number.
Again, we have the 5% rule
there.
This is the hydronium ion
concentration,
that was x.
Now we can find out the pH by
taking minus the log of that
value, and that gives us an
answer of 3.45.
And we have two significant
figures after the decimal point
because there were two
significant figures in the
volume.
All right.
That is how you look at a
buffer problem.
And now we can say,
was this a good buffer?
Let's consider what happens if
we add some strong acid,
HCl, 0.1 moles of it to this
solution.
Again, in this case we are
keeping the total volume at one
liter.
If you had made up your buffer
and added that 0.1 moles of the
strong acid to it,
what would be your pH?
Is it about the same,
or did it dramatically change
the pH of the solution?
All right.
Now you have to do some
subtractions to do this kind of
problem, and you have to
remember what we know about
strong acids.
HCl is definitely a strong
acid.
And so we assume that when we
add 0.1 moles of it that it is
going to react completely.
When we are adding the 0.1
moles, it will react with equal
number of moles of the base.
The base is going to act as the
sink for protons,
it will react with the acid and
you will form the conjugate,
the same equal number of moles
of a conjugate.
Here the base is reacting with
the acid and trying to
neutralize the pH.
If we consider the HCOO minus
here, what we had originally,
we had 0.5 moles.
Now it has reacted with 0.1
moles of the HCl.
And so you only have 0.4 left.
And we have 0.4 in one liter.
We always need to convert to
molarity for these problems.
Now, in terms of the conjugate
acid over here,
we had one mole to begin with.
Now we have 0.1 moles more
because the strong acid reacted
with the conjugate base to form
more of the conjugate acid.
Now our total is 1.1,
and that 1.1 is in that one
liter.
And so we have a new molarity.
Now we can just do the same
thing we did before and solve
for x, the hydronium ion
concentration,
which will give us the pH.
We can set up this expression
again.
Now we have to put in our new
amounts, our 1.1 over here and
our 0.4 over here.
We are still going to reach an
equilibrium.
x will be converted to plus x
over here.
We have 1.1 minus x,
0.4 plus x.
We can use the same Ka value
that we had before to solve.
We can use the same
approximations.
Set up the same equations.
Put in our new values over
here.
Do the same simplification.
See if that works.
Solve for x.
The value for x now is
4.87x10^-4.
And that is still okay.
It's only 0.12% of the smaller
number, the 0.4 number.
That is less than 5% so it is
fine.
And we can solve then for pH.
And now we get a pH of 3.31,
two significant figures after
the decimal point.
We had before,
initially in a solution that
didn't have the strong acid,
a pH of 3.45 with 0.1 moles of
strong acid added.
The pH has changed slightly to
3.31.
That is a decent buffer.
It didn't change really
dramatically when you added some
strong acid.
This is a way that you can
manipulate a buffer,
if you are trying to design a
buffer at an exact pH.
Then you can calculate.
You look at what kind of
buffering agent you want to use
and figure out how much strong
acid or base you might have to
add to it to sort of adjust the
pH to where you want it to be.
That is one way of doing a
buffer problem.
Now let's consider designing a
buffer, and how we would think
about going about it if you are
in a biochem lab,
for example,
and you need to buffer
something at this pH,
how could you set these things
up?
Some of the things you would
think about are the ratio of the
acid to its conjugate,
so the conjugate acid base
pair, what ratio they have.
The pKa of the acid.
What pH you want to be for your
particular condition.
All right.
Now we are going to drive an
equation that is going to help
you in designing buffers and in
doing buffer problems.
Here comes a derivation.
The derivation starts with a
generic equation for an acid
buffer problem.
We have an acid,
HA, in water forming hydronium
ions and the conjugate base.
We also know Ka,
the generic expression for Ka,
products over reactants.
Or, in the case of this acid in
water, we have hydronium ions
times the conjugate base over
the conjugate acid.
Now we can take this expression
and rearrange it.
We can bring Ka to the other
side and hydronium ions to the
other side of the equation.
And then we can take the log of
both sides of the equation and
multiply both sides by minus 1.
This is the equation that we
would get as the result of those
manipulations.
What is minus log of the
hydronium ion concentration?
What else is that equal to?
pH.
And what about minus log of Ka,
what is that equal to?
pKa.
We can substitute those in.
pH is going to equal pKa minus
the log of the concentration of
the acid over the concentration
of its conjugate base.
Here there are equilibrium
concentrations because it came
from that equilibrium
expression.
Now, this is not that useful an
expression to us.
We want to see whether we can
make it more useful.
And what would make it more
useful is if we consider the
initial concentrations of the
acid and its conjugate base
rather than the equilibrium
concentrations.
This will make it a more useful
expression.
At least Henderson and
Hasselbalch thought that was a
pretty useful expression,
and I guess other people
thought it was as well since now
it has the name
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation.
Usually things don't get named
unless they turn out to be
fairly useful.
The simplification,
the approximation that is being
made here, is that the initial
concentrations are similar
enough to the equilibrium
concentrations.
Let's consider when,
in fact, that would be true.
Here are the same expressions
again.
What this is really saying is
that x is small,
something that we have been
talking about for the last
couple of days.
x, in this case,
is the acid in equilibrium with
its conjugate base.
x, the hydronium ion
concentration,
is small compared to the
initial concentration of the
acid in the conjugate base.
The equilibrium concentrations
are more or less the same as the
initial concentrations.
This is that approximation that
we have been using,
and we had been using that 5%
rule, which we will continue to
use for the
Henderson-Hasselbalch.
This is assuming x is pretty
small.
Another way of thinking about
this is that a weak acid
typically only loses a small
fraction of its protons or
hydrogen ions.
It is weak.
By definition,
a weak acid only loses a small
amount.
A strong acid,
on the other hand,
pretty much ionizes completely.
And a weak base typically only
accepts a small fraction of
protons or hydrogen ions.
Most of the time,
x is small; most of the time
there isn't a huge change,
and most of the time you can
use that 5% rule.
Most of the time the initial
concentrations are not all that
different from the equilibrium
concentrations.
This holds a lot of the time.
And, again, the rule we will be
using is this 5% that the
concentration of hydronium ions
needs to be small,
this over HA or A minus,
whichever of these is
the small number,
needs to be less than 5%.
And if it is then you can use
this expression.
And that expression,
you will find out,
turns out to make your lives a
lot easier in doing these
problems.
Now let's use this to design a
buffer.
When would you use
Henderson-Hasselbalch?
We can consider it right here.
Now, suppose you wanted a
buffer that is going to buffer
in the acidic range,
around 4.6.
What we would do is go to a
table in the book and see which
acids have a pKa around 4.6.
And we could look down here.
That one is pretty close.
Let's see.
Acetic acid,
that is not bad.
That is around that pH.
Let's pick that one.
There are a couple other
options, but that was one that
would work.
Acidic acid is suitable.
It has a pKa of 4.75.
And we want something around
the pH of 4.6.
And so most buffer solutions,
something that is effective to
buffer at a particular pH if its
pKa is plus or minus one from
that pH, if the pKa is more than
one away from the desired pH
that is not going to be a
particularly good buffer.
You want it within that range
of plus or minus one.
And that becomes important if
you have, say,
an enzyme that you are studying
in a biochemistry lab.
If you are doing it at the
wrong pH, the enzyme may not be
happy at all.
You might not get any results.
Let's use Henderson-Hasselbalch
now to consider how much of each
thing we should add to make a
pretty good buffer.
Here is our equation again.
And we can consider these
original concentrations of the
acid and its conjugate base.
Now we can rearrange this to
solve for things that we know.
We know the pKa and we know the
pH that we want.
And so the pKa was 4.75.
The pH that we want is 4.6.
We subtract that and get 0.15.
And then if we do inverse log
over here, we find that the
ratio of the acid to the
conjugate base that we should
add is a 1.4 ratio of those two.
What does this mean?
How much would you then add?
Well, you could,
with this ratio,
add 1.4 molar of the acid and
one molar of the conjugate base.
But the exact amounts are not
as important as the ratio.
The ratio here is quite
important because,
again, for it to be a good
buffer it needs to be able to go
both directions.
If you add strong acid,
then that strong acid needs to
be able to react with the
conjugate base to keep the pH
constant.
If you add strong base,
it needs to be able to react
with the conjugate acid,
again, to keep the pH constant.
The ratio is important here.
The ratio is more important
than the exact amounts.
But if you add too little then
you do not have enough of what's
called buffering capacity,
and you have less resistance to
change.
The more that you have,
the more resistant to change
the buffer will be.
So, if you have higher
concentrations,
the less likely it is that
there will be a problem that you
will sort of swamp out your
system by adding too much acid
or base.
And if you use too low
concentrations then you are not
going to make your 5% rule.
And the Henderson-Hasselbalch
equation will not be valid and
you will not end up with the pH
that you think you are going to
because this will not tell you
the right answer under those
conditions.
What would that be?
Well, you can go back and
calculate what is sort of the
minimum concentration that one
would need to keep your 5% rule?
For a pH of 4.6,
that is equal to hydronium ion
concentration of 2.5x10^-5.
And so if you put that up here
then either of these,
the smaller one of these,
for this to be less than 5%,
you can go back and calculate.
And so you would need at least
5x10^-4 over here for the 5%
rule to work.
If you had less than that,
then the equation wouldn't be
valid.
OK.
We are working our way through
this list, and we will move into
today's handout.
Remember, there are only five
types of problems,
and the trick is to figure out
which type of problem it is and
apply the right kind of
procedure to it.
Again, the two easiest ones we
have left are the strong acid
and the strong base in water.
And then we are going to go
into acid-base titrations which,
in one problem of an acid-base
titration, you can do almost all
of these different types of
problems.
Titrations are really a summary
of all the types of problems put
into one problem.
Acid-base titrations.
And I will say,
before we get started,
that acid-base titration
problems are often the problems
in this half of the course that
people struggle with,
although the year before last
there was an actually quite good
performance on acid-base
titrations.
And so last year I told the
class that the year before had
been quite good,
and I was curious to see how
they would do in comparison to
this pretty good year.
And they responded and did a
really fantastic job.
So I am beginning to think that
this, in fact,
is not a hard unit necessarily.
It is a little bit different,
I think, but you just have to
work the problems.
And there are problems on the
problem set to work.
And then it starts to come
together.
I am really optimistic that
this year's class can even
outperform last year's class.
I mean you did on Exam 2,
so I feel like this will be a
little contest to see if people
can do better than last year.
Acid-base titrations,
you will see them again.
If you take organic chemistry,
you will talk about pKa's all
the time.
Biochemistry,
you are going to talk about
acids and bases and buffers and
pKa's.
If any of you are going to
medical school,
oh boy, will it be back big
time.
When I was a graduate student I
TA'ed medical students,
and pretty much all we were
doing was acid-base titrations,
getting through it.
If you learn it now,
you are just going to make
many, many years ahead be much
easier.
All right.
Acid-base titrations,
what is this?
Well, you are basically
titrating an acid with a base or
a base with an acid.
Often they are used to find out
an unknown concentration.
If you know the concentration
of one thing you are adding,
you can find out the other.
Let's just look at some of
these things.
Here you would have a strong
base on top, in this picture,
and a strong acid in this flask
here.
And you are dripping amounts of
strong base into the strong
acid.
And you can calculate out a
titration curve.
Here we have pH versus volume
of base added.
At the very beginning,
we are very acidic pH.
We only have strong acid at
zero volume.
And then, as you add base,
you eventually get to a point
called the equivalence point or
the stoichiometric point or
sometimes called the end point.
And here are some of the
definitions of those.
Basically here the number of
moles of acid is equal to the
number of moles of base that you
have added, so equivalence or
stoichiometric because they are
equal amounts here.
And it is often called the end
point because experimentally,
when you get to that point,
you are at the end of your
experiment.
And this one is really a
theoretical.
This is experimental.
They should,
in fact, equal each other.
You can measure pH up here with
the pH meter.
And when you are doing these
kinds of acid-base titrations,
you often see something like
this.
You have some kind of dye which
indicates when you have reached
the endpoint.
And so it will be clear,
clear, clear and then all of a
sudden you will start seeing
this change in color.
And you want to measure the
endpoint when you just start to
see that change.
How many of you have actually
done these titrations in a lab?
Almost everybody,
okay.
What happens often,
at least when I did it,
you would be going along really
slowly, drip,
any change, drip,
any change.
And finally you just get
incredibly frustrated and you
add just a little bit more,
and all of a sudden it is
really, really bright color and
you have gone too far.
But then you can sometimes back
calculate approximately where
the end point should be and go
fast to that point and then go
kind of slowly.
And so it sometimes helps to be
able to do these sort of
theoretical calculations to help
you figure out when you need to
drip slowly.
How many of you have had that
same kind of experience of
really, really slow and then all
of a sudden bright colors?
How many people did it
perfectly one time?
OK.
We have just a handful of
people who did that perfectly.
All right.
Some people ask me,
why don't we have a lab course
affiliated with our GIR courses?
A lot of times you have a lab
course for freshman chemistry or
for first year physics and this
kind of thing.
It would be hard because you
take so many science courses at
once to have a lot of the labs,
let alone the number of people.
But I tell people mostly you
are not missing out too much in
the freshman experience.
Because I think most freshman
college courses,
pretty much this is what you do
most of the semester.
So, you have already done it.
And you will learn how to do it
on paper.
And so the next couple days,
this problem set,
you can declare that a lab
experience and feel like you
have saved yourself an
incredible amount of time by not
actually being in a laboratory
doing the drip,
drip, drip, drip experiment.
You are not missing out on too
much for this.
Later courses,
I think the labs become
increasingly valuable to
understanding the material and
can be a lot of fun.
And, of course,
research experience is
fantastic.
The UROP program here is
spectacular.
All right.
Acid-base titrations here.
Let's look at the shapes of the
other kind of curve.
We can do the reverse
experiment and have strong acid
up here dripping into strong
base.
And so in the beginning you
just have strong base,
so you are up here in the
curve.
You add some until you get to
the stoichiometric or
equivalence point,
and then it is equal amounts of
acid and base.
And then, as you keep adding,
your pH drops because then you
start having more strong acid in
here.
These are the shapes of these
curves, and you should know how
to draw these and you should
know how to calculate various
different points on those
curves.
Let's look at that.
Here we have a strong base,
NaOH, and it is being titrated
with a strong acid,
HCl.
And so we are going to
calculate just a couple of
points on that curve.
Let's start by doing 5 ml's of
the acid that has been added to
25 milliliters of our strong
base.
And let's figure out what the
pH will be at 5.
First, what we have to do is
calculate how much OH is
present.
And remember for strong acids,
strong bases,
you say that the amount of NaOH
added is going to be equal to
the amount of OH formed.
The NaOH completely ionizes
into sodium plus and OH
minus.
We can calculate the number of
moles.
We know the volume.
We know the concentration.
We had 25 ml's.
We know this and can calculate
the numbers of moles.
Then we have to figure out how
much acid was added.
We added 5 milliliters.
What does that correspond to in
terms of moles?
Again, it is a strong acid.
We can say for the amount of
HCl that was added,
we have formed completely
hydronium ion.
It is completely ionized.
It is a strong acid.
You have complete conversion to
the acidic form to hydronium
ion.
We had 5 ml's times the
concentration of acid that was
given.
And now we know how many moles
of acid were added.
Now we are going to have a
reaction between the base and
the acid, so these will react.
And so if we had 6.25x10^-3
moles of hydroxide ion,
and we are going to subtract
the amount of acid that is
formed to find out how much OH
is left.
We just subtract those.
There is a complete reaction,
one to one.
And so we just subtract the
amount of acid to get the
numbers of moles.
Then we need to convert that to
molarity.
Here, we have the number of
moles that we just calculated
divided by our new volume.
We added 5 ml's of acid and we
had 25 ml's to begin with,
so now we have 30 total and we
can calculate the concentration.
And I will just mention that
this is one of the common
mistakes that people make on
exams when you are hurrying,
and it is not to actually
figure out the total volume that
you have at that moment.
Put maybe a little star by it
to remind yourself to do this
addition here,
because if you have the wrong
volume all your numbers start
coming out very strangely.
Once you have the
concentration,
then it is easy to calculate
pOH.
Now, this is,
again, the concentration of
hydroxide ions that we had.
If we take the minus log of
that, we get the pOH.
And then
we need to change it to pH.
All of the problems you will do
are at room temperature,
so you can always use 14 for
your conversion,
and you come out with a pH of
13.18.
Now we have our first spot on
the titration curve.
We had volume of acid.
We were adding 5 ml's to begin
with.
This is pH.
And we are starting out here.
That's back a little.
At 5 ml's we are up at 13.18,
so we are at quite basic pH.
And remember that as you are
doing these problems,
if you had ended here and
decided that was your pH,
think about the fact that you
have mostly strong base at that
point.
You realize you need to do this
conversion to go to pH.
Now let's figure out about the
equivalence point.
We need to know the volume to
get to the equivalence point.
How much acid do we need to
add?
Well, initially we know how
much OH was present.
At the equivalence point,
by the name equivalence or
stoichiometric,
you need equal amounts of the
acid.
If this is how much we had in
moles, this is how much we are
going to need in moles of HCl.
We just need to find out what
volume we need to add to get
those numbers of moles.
And so here are the moles.
This was the concentration of
acid we were given.
And so that means we are going
to need 18.4 milliliters to
reach the stoichiometric or
equivalence point.
And what will be the pH at that
equivalence point?
Strong acid mixed with a strong
base.
7.
It will be neutral.
Somewhere around here,
we are going to have a pH of 7
when we get to 18.4 milliliters
of acid added.
Strong acid,
strong base,
the equivalence point pH will
always be 7.
If you are starting to talk
about a weak acid or a weak
base, it will not be 7,
but for strong acid,
strong base it will always be
7, will always be neutral.
What about if we add 1 ml
extra?
We have reached the
stoichiometric or equivalence
point, and now we are going to
add an extra mL of acid,
what is going to happen?
You can do this a couple of
different ways.
I think this is probably the
simplest, is just to say how
many extra moles is that?
If concentration was 0.34,
we are adding 1 mL extra,
so we are going to add
3.4x10^-4 moles of acid extra.
And then we just need to find
out the concentration of that.
The only trick here again is to
remember that you have to add up
all of the correct volume.
You had 25 to begin with.
You have added 18.4 milliliters
to get to the equivalence point
and you have added 1 mL beyond
the equivalence point,
so you have this new volume.
And we have this number of
moles of acid.
Then you can calculate the
concentration from that and then
take minus log of that number to
get the pH.
And so we can put that down
here.
When we go sort of 1 milliliter
beyond, now we are down at a pH
around 2.116.
We started at very basic pH.
We added 18.4 milliliters to
get to pH 7, to the equivalence
point.
And then, if we keep adding
acid, the pH drops pretty
dramatically.
And now you are quite acidic.
That is how you would calculate
points on a curve for a strong
acid, strong base titration.
And so we will have two kinds
of curve shapes here.
This one that we just talked
about.
And then, of course,
if you are going to the other
direction, you will start at a
low pH when you have acid,
reach the stoichiometry point
at pH 7 and then keep going.
As you add more base,
it will get more basic.
Now let's talk about when the
acid is weak or strong.
The only kinds of problems
here, you either have strong
with strong or you have a weak
acid with a strong base.
Or strong with strong.
Then we also could have a weak
base and a strong acid,
but you never are going to have
two weak things titrating each
other.
That is not a kind of problem
you will see.
Here I just want to show the
difference in curve shapes.
We talked about this one,
this strong with strong curve
shape, where the equivalence
point is pH 7.
Now let's look at the
difference over here,
when the acid that is being
titrated is weak.
A couple things you will
notice.
One is that the equivalence
point no longer has a pH of 7.
It's a pH that is greater than
7.
And another thing that you will
notice is the curve shape down
here is kind of odd.
It flattens out in a region.
And this is called the
buffering region.
And partway through the
buffering region,
in the middle of the buffering
region you have a point called
the half equivalence point.
And that is the point when you
have added half of the volume to
convert half of the acid that
you started with to its
conjugate.
You are halfway to the
equivalence point.
And that is a special kind of
category of problem.
Let's look at what is happening
at various points in this
titration.
Let's look at what happens when
you start this problem.
When you start doing a
titration problem and you have a
weak acid being titrated with a
strong base, at volume equals
zero, all you have is your weak
acid.
All you have is a weak acid,
and so this is a weak acid in
water problem.
At the very start of the
titration, that is the first
problem that we worked in class.
You have a weak acid in water
problem, so you know how to
solve those.
This is my little cartoon for
an acid.
We have A.
It is HA.
And so this is going to be
titrated off.
The acid is going to be losing
its proton or hydrogen ion to
interact with a strong base.
Now, when we start adding a
strong base, we are going to
move into this buffering region
here.
And so, as we are adding the
strong base, the strong base is
going to start stripping off the
protons of the hydrogen atoms.
And leaving the conjugate base
of the weak acid that we had to
begin with.
And so when you have an acid
and its conjugate base both
present in solution that is a
buffer problem,
so you can be going both
directions.
And the buffering region is the
region of the plot that is
pretty much flat.
And what does flat mean?
Well, flat means this is
against the scale of pH.
Flat means the pH isn't
changing much.
Well, that's what a buffer
does.
It keeps the pH fairly
constant.
You are going to be moving into
this buffering region.
And if you were doing these
kinds of titrations in lab,
these are even more frustrating
than the ones I just showed you.
Because when you reach the
buffering region you keep adding
and adding and adding and the pH
is not changing at all.
You are just adding and adding
and the pH does not change.
Then all of a sudden it just
goes wild and you jump way up to
here.
And so that is what is
happening in this curve.
You don't have much of a pH
change in this region.
All right.
When we get to the middle point
of the buffering region,
we have a special category.
And the volume here is the
volume at the half equivalence
point.
You have added half the number
of moles in this case to the
strong base that you need.
When you have added half the
amount, you have converted half
of the acid to its conjugate
base.
You have a 50/50 mixture here.
This is a special category.
When the amount of the weak
acid equals the amount of the
conjugate base that is being
formed.
Notice, as we go up,
here it was all acid,
here there is some mixture,
here there is more mixture.
You are titrating off,
you are pulling off these
hydrogen ions as the titration
goes forward.
Once we reach the equivalence
point, you have pulled off all
the hydrogen ions,
you have removed all of the
protons from the weak acid,
and now all you have is the
conjugate base.
Really, what you formed here is
a salt.
But this salt is a conjugate
base of a weak acid,
so it is going to be basic.
It really is just a weak base
in water problem.
And that is why the pH is
greater than 7 here,
because what you are left with
at the equivalence point,
when you have pulled off all of
the protons is a base,
so it will be above 7.
Not dramatically above 7,
because it is a weak base,
but it will be above 7.
And then, as you keep going,
you still have this around.
You still have a conjugate base
around, but now you are really
just adding strong base.
It is not reacting with
anything.
You are jumping up in pH quite
dramatically as you do that.
And, really,
this is just a strong base in
water problem,
like the one that we just
talked about.
In doing one titration,
all these points along here,
you are doing a weak base
problem, a buffer problem,
a special category of buffer
problem, a weak base problem and
a strong base problem.
In every titration there are
just five different really kinds
of problems.
You just need to recognize
where you are in the titration
and which type of problem you
should be doing.
Just going the other direction,
it is the same thing in
reverse.
Now here we have a weak base
that we are titrating with a
strong acid.
At volume equals zero,
it is just a weak base problem.
As you start to add acid,
the acid is protonating the
base.
And so now you have some
conjugate acid of your weak
base.
so again, it is a buffer
problem.
At the half equivalence point
these guys are equal to each
other.
You have converted half of your
weak base to its conjugate acid.
And when you get to the
equivalence point,
you have converted all of your
weak base to its conjugate acid.
This is a weak acid in water
problem, and so we would expect
the pH here to be less than 7
because we are acidic at this
point.
And when we get all the way
past the equivalence point,
then we are just talking about
how much extra strong acid we
have added.
Again, it is the same type of
problems.
In this case you are
protonating.
You are starting with base,
and you keep protonating it
until you have converted it all
to acid.
Let's see if we can do a couple
of points along this curve.
Now we are talking about a weak
acid being titrated with a
strong base.
And I will move fairly quickly
through some of these because we
have already seen how to do
these parts a couple of times.
The trick to titration is just
to recognize what type of
problem it is.
In the beginning,
we added no base.
This is just a weak acid
problem.
We have our acid in water
forming hydronium ion and a
conjugate base.
We are given a Ka value.
This is just a weak acid
problem.
We can set up our plot here.
We had 0.1 molar to begin with.
And at equilibrium we will have
0.1 minus x, x and x.
We can plug this into the Ka
expression.
x squared over 0.1 minus x.
We can
assume x is small.
Simplify this to x squared over
0.1.
Solve for x,
which is now 0.00421.
We can check that this is less
than 0.1 and is less than 5%.
It is 4.2% so it is less than
5%.
We are OK.
We can make that assumption.
We don't have to do the
quadratic equation.
And so then we can plug x,
which is the hydronium ion
concentration,
into this expression and solve
for our pH.
Then we can put a plot over
here.
We have one point.
And here is volume of base
added versus pH.
And we start down here,
before we have added any base,
and we are at a pH of 2.38.
All right.
Now let's look at a problem in
the buffering region real
quickly.
Now, what happens if we have
added some small amount,
5 mLs less than the volume at
the equivalence point of our
base?
The OH is strong.
It will react completely with
our acid.
It is much stronger than the
conjugate, so we will have a
reaction.
We need to do the subtraction
at first and assume the amount
of strong base you add will
react completely with whatever
acid is available.
We know how much acid we had to
begin with, volume and a
concentration,
so we know the number of moles.
We also can calculate the
number of moles of hydroxide
ion.
We know the volume added and we
know the concentration,
so we have this number of
moles.
Then the moles after the
reaction.
We had 2.5x10^3 before.
Now we subtract the amount of
hydroxide ion and come up with
new moles of acid,
the moles of acid that are
left.
That amount of base is also
going to produce the conjugate.
This guy is going to be
converted to this guy,
so we will have that number of
moles of conjugate base that is
formed.
This is like a buffer problem.
We need to convert to molarity
first.
We know the volume.
We had 25 mLs,
plus we have now added 5 mLs.
And we have two new
concentrations that we can plug
in here.
That is how much acid we have
left after the reaction with OH.
This is how much conjugate is
formed after the reaction and
then at equilibrium.
And we can just go through,
make the same approximations
that this is small,
come up with x,
check it and come up with a new
pH.
Okay.
That is option one.
And on Wednesday we will talk
about another option for the
buffer problem,
which is looking at the
Henderson-Hasselbalch.